the crowds came out to see him on his
trip to a Soweto area polling booth and
he flashed his broad and confident smile
but Cyril Ramaphosa is fighting for his
political life in a feisty and
hard-fought campaign it's a real crush
everybody wants a picture of Cyril
Ramaphosa and there is enthusiasm there
is excitement for him if not the party
and his party is the problem after 25
years in power the ANC is bedeviled by
allegations of corruption and poor
governance but ROM opposer says he can
turn it all around a new beginning and a
new period of renewal then he promised
to deal with the rot in the ANC what we
never never never again myself
Africa go through what we have gone
through where there is sleaze where
there's malfeasance where there is
rampant corruption
that's a promise many here will struggle
to believe over the line in this
election
[Music]
but the party that dismantled apartheid
doesn't dominate the landscape like it
did opposition parties at the economic
freedom fighters have found their voice
they're led by a fire brand called
Julius Malema who promises to
expropriate land from the white minority
and hand it to blacks I feel very proud
of myself that I'm not like the rest who
take for granted this voting
they've won themselves a receptive
audience in a country with ten million
people work although most voters we
spoke to they give the ANC another
chance you know what it's not Sarah you
do corruption who did a fight
let's put several this side said I would
do the good wing really I'm telling you
the honest truth you'll see my brother
people still have faith in the ANC but
remember when you get in there it's your
your votes that's gonna speak and you
can't really tell whether it's gonna be
a true reflection of what they say when
you interview them there are plenty of
political offerings to choose from
including the country's largest
opposition party the democratic alliance
but this is a contest for mr. Romm
opposer to win or lose and it's a
contest not a coronation John sparks Sky
News
Soweto